[Música]
el metaverso se está volviendo cada vez
más popular y está llegando hasta las
universidades cambiando incluso la forma
tradicional de defender una tesis de
grado por ejemplo hablamos del caso de
julio sawers ember alumno del máster de
gestión del patrimonio y turismo
sostenible de la universidad autónoma de
chile que defendió su tesis en el
metaverso gracias a esta tecnología
pudieron entonces estar juntos en el
escenario virtual tanto académicos
localizados en la ciudad de temuco como
en la capital santiago haciendo la
experiencia mucho más atractiva e
inmersiva y sólo a través de una
pantalla saludamos entonces al
protagonista de todo esto julio shawer
samberg e ingeniero en informática y
alumno del máster de gestión de
patrimonio y turismo sostenible de la
universidad autónoma de chile que
defendió su tesis como ya lo estábamos
diciendo en el metaverso julio gracias
por estar esta mañana de viernes con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
discúlpame si no pronuncie muy bien en
tu apellido pero bueno vamos a la
materia la idea como se le ocurrió esto
de defender su tesis y grado en el
metaverso además como la recibieron sus
profesores
buenos días a todos
trabajando en el desarrollo de care
de witte 7 grados richter y
estuve haciendo siempre en un contexto
tecnológico
de informática médica
a trabajar en esto
y un grado académico que es
turismo sostenible
entonces quise vincular la entrada del
turismo en el café
de poder proyectar hacia el futuro y
poder
generar experiencias previas a los
pechos para poder
e
físicamente y eso julio qué pena que lo
interrumpa pero eso es lo que yo le
quería puedes plantear a usted y que
conversemos sobre esto como esto de
digamos hacer turismo o viajar a otros
lugares digamos dentro el metaverso y
poder tener una digamos una experiencia
bien inmersiva y bien confortante no
para tratar de alguna manera no sé si se
puede decir esa palabra pero competir
con lo que conocemos ahora con el
turismo tradicional por ejemplo también
en todo esto que tiene que ver con el
cambio climático que sabemos que la
huella turística deja enormes
consecuencias para nuestro ambiente
si el efecto bueno es decir lo que
propone es un aporte una herramienta
para promover el turismo pero pero no
viene a reemplazar lo que es el turismo
tradicional la verdad es que cuando se
pretende apoyar al turismo
y a las personas que quizás no pueden
viajar algún algún lugar por un tema
económico o un tema físico la idea de
que esto sea inclusivo respondo por el
ría cara a otros países sin tener que
tener que gastar dinero o por alguna
característica física que le impida
por ejemplo animal área y experiencia
que te pueden acercar un poco de salir
ver y yo crearía también julio personaje
por ejemplo van a ir a un destino
turístico que nunca han visitado poder
hacer esta visita digamos en el
metaverso para conocer un poco la ciudad
a la que van a visitar pero les quiero
preguntar entonces la complejidad de
poder desarrollar estos y además esta
idea ya usted la está conversando con
empresas para poder llevarla a cabo si
ya las personas pueden de hacer de este
turismo inmersivo a través de el
metaverso
o sea yo estoy trabajando con algunas
personas para ver que
este concepto de u2 de humedad está
recién empezando la verdad y entonces
hay muchas cosas por hacer
pero bueno estamos en la parte inicial
solamente hoy día lo importante es que
entreguemos el contenido en lo que
respecta al turismo
apoyando a la pequeña y mediana empresa
que en el fondo se ven beneficiadas por
esta ideología que falta por hacer en el
metaverso a corto plazo julio y también
le quiero preguntar digamos si una
persona que no está familiarizada con
todo esto el metaverso cómo puede
ingresar todavía no está digamos
democratizado el metaverso para pues
todo el mundo que quiera acceder a él
bueno
hoy día solamente un concepto y como tal
lo que conocemos son
los proto de éstos quienes fondos son lo
primero que nada de esto pero el metal
esto en sí es una tecnología que que aún
no existe y que vamos camino hacia eso
muy bien para poder ingresar al metal
versos como realmente es el
utilizar algunos como algunas imágenes
que hice la presentación
bueno hay varias marcas de variados
precios y obviamente la calidad de cada
uno depende
de lo que uno quiera la experiencia que
uno quiere vivir
julio y hablando de experiencias digamos
cuando nosotros podemos disfrutar de
esto como si tan fácil como meternos
nosotros ingresar a una red social por
ejemplo que tanto que tanto le falta a
este sector para que ya todo el mundo
pueda tener ingreso a su meta versus su
mundo el metaverso su avatar
lo que tienen que pasar es que tienen
que bajar los precios de estos equipos
que realmente son bastante costosos para
tener una experiencia de calidad hay que
tener un gas hay que
desembolsar un costo alto para obtener
los lentes obviamente como pasó con los
celulares esto va a ir pasando con
abrirán tiempo